please welcome from CD Projekt RED lead
designer Damien Mon yay
hello everyone something that really
really amazed us after we release
Witcher 3 is that in this huge huge open
world place took a lot of time to just
sit down in taverns and play cards
in fact it was so excited about the card
game that it sent us thousands of emails
asking us to turn it into standalone and
some of our most inspired fans if it
made their own physical decks so that
they could play with their friends so we
listened to them and over the last year
we've been secretly working on a real
passion project so ladies and gentlemen
how about a game of quit
awesome we've turned went into a
full-blown multiplayer experience and
thanks to its cross play feature you can
battle people from around the world
regardless of whether they use pcs or
consoles and on top of that we're also
creating a monumental single-player
campaign now we've kept the core
mechanics that made Gwent fun but we've
improved on them we've added new ones
and we've also redesigned the visuals
almost completely however the most
important thing is though that Gwent is
still a card game that's based on skill
so it puts you not just your cards in
the center of things now that's cool
quent is a clash of two armies on the
battlefield basically and our fans love
the fact that you only get ten cards at
the beginning of a game and that's your
hand until the end so you have to play
small you have to bluff and in some
cases you may even not want to lose
around in order to take the game at the
decisive moment your deck is the army
that fights for you and army you recruit
from among four factions each offering a
play style and different tactics as well
so first the Skellig warriors and their
mighty berserkers northern realms and
their powerful siege engines the shadowy
sneaky squirtle and of course the nasty
brutal monsters as you win and craft new
cards over time you'll gain more options
to basically smash your opponent in
clever ways because at the end we'll
play to win don't we so go to play Gwen
calm to register for the exclusive beta
available first on Xbox one and Windows
PC and it's coming this September so
whoa not long to wait listen thank you
all and of course thanks to my amazing
dev team back in Warsaw I know you're
watching us right now
kisses love you guys see you all at the
Gwen table